Elias stopped eating meat when he was three or four. His mom can't remember-- it's been so long. He's seven now. And he doesn't think that anybody else should eat meat either, and he freaks out. He cried and pleaded at his grandmother's at New Year's when he heard that she might cook brisket, until she offered not to. There was the time that he got so upset in a restaurant smelling the meat cooking in the kitchen and seeing all the people around them eat their meals that he had to go sit up front by the door.
埃利亚斯在三四岁时就不再吃肉了。他妈妈记不清具体是什么时候了——毕竟已经过去太久了。他现在七岁。他认为其他人也不应该吃肉，而且为此感到非常崩溃。新年在祖母家时，他听说祖母可能要做牛腩，于是哭闹哀求，直到祖母答应不做了。还有一次在餐馆里，他闻到厨房里烹饪肉食的味道，看到周围的人都在吃肉，他感到非常难过，不得不坐到靠近门口的前面位置。
And it kills him especially to think that his little brother might still be eating animals. His brother, Theo, just turned five and emphatically is not a vegetarian. What a surprise, two brothers. Their mom, Rachel, says that Theo is not asking to eat meat in front of Elias. He's not asking to eat it all that often.
想到他弟弟可能还在吃动物，这让他特别痛苦。他的弟弟西奥刚满五岁，而且明确表示自己不是素食主义者。真让人惊讶，兄弟俩。他们的妈妈瑞秋说，西奥不会在埃利亚斯面前吵着要吃肉。他并没有那么频繁地要求吃肉。
He wants to eat meat sometimes. And I think he feels it's not fair that Elias-- he calls him the god of food-- and that Elias doesn't have the right to be the god of food and tell Theo what to do. It causes a lot of conflict, and I think there are conversations almost every single day around this.
他有时确实想吃肉。我觉得他觉得不公平，因为埃利亚斯——他称埃利亚斯为“食物之神”——埃利亚斯没有权力成为“食物之神”并告诉西奥该怎么做。这引发了许多冲突，我想几乎每天都会围绕这个问题产生争论。
She recorded one of those conversations for us when she was taking Theo, the meat eater, to a party. There was going to be food at the party, and his brother was going to be there, the god of food. What would Theo eat?
在瑞秋带“肉食者”西奥去参加聚会时，她为我们录下了其中一次对话。聚会上会有食物，而他的哥哥，那位“食物之神”也会在那里。西奥会吃什么呢？
So Theo, we're going to this potluck. What do you think's going to be there?
那么西奥，我们要去参加这个百乐餐聚会。你觉得那里会有什么？
Well, I hope there's meat. And if you give me meat, just let me eat it.
嗯，我希望有肉。如果你们给我肉，就让我吃吧。
So what do you think would happen if you ate meat at the potluck?
那你觉得如果你在聚会上吃肉会发生什么？
Well, we would-- Elias would fight.
嗯，我们会……埃利亚斯会打架。
You and Elias would fight?
你和埃利亚斯会打架？
Yeah. Well, that would be bad. But I don't know what's going to happen.
是的。嗯，那会很糟糕。但我不知道会发生什么。
Tonight is a night for Elias' class. Do you think you could not eat meat tonight so he doesn't have to have a freak out in front of all of his friends? What do you think?
今晚是埃利亚斯班级的聚会。你觉得今晚能不能不吃肉，这样他就不用在所有朋友面前崩溃了？你觉得呢？
No. I want to eat some because he always says don't eat any meat for the rest of your life.
不。我想吃一点，因为他总是说让我这辈子都不要吃肉。
I know. I think things will change when he gets older. But I just want you to think about whether or not you think it's worth it for him to scream and yell at school tonight with all of his friends, OK? Think about that. OK? Deal?
我知道。我想等他长大些情况会有所改变。但我只是想让你考虑一下，今晚在学校里让他当着所有朋友的面大喊大叫是否值得，好吗？考虑一下。好吗？成交？
Well, when he's not looking, I'll eat some.
嗯，等他不注意的时候，我会吃一点。
When he's not looking?
等他不注意的时候？
Yeah.
是的。
Hmm.
嗯。
Do you think this gives Elias too much power over Theo?
你觉得这是否给了埃利亚斯太多控制西奥的权力？
Yeah. I mean, it's definitely a concern. And at some point, probably a year into his vegetarianism, he asked that we wouldn't be eating meat either and that the house wouldn't have any meat. And that was something that my husband and I had to take a step back and think about.
是的。我是说，这绝对是一个令人担忧的问题。在他吃素大概一年的时候，他曾要求我们也不要吃肉，家里也不要有任何肉食。那是让我和丈夫不得不退后一步仔细考虑的事情。
And people would say to us, how can you have your seven-year-old making decisions about how you're going to be running your family? And I guess our response has always been, you have to hear how our child talks about meat and how it feels to him when he sees us eat meat and other people around him and his close family eating meat. It's such a painful experience for him.
人们会问我们，怎么能让一个七岁的孩子决定你们家庭的运行方式？我想我们的回答一直是，你必须听到我们的孩子是如何谈论肉食的，以及当他看到我们吃肉，看到他身边的人和亲人吃肉时，他内心是什么感受。对他来说，那是一种非常痛苦的经历。
OK, I just want to say before we go any further, if you are hearing all this and you're feeling judgy about these parents-- and I know you are because that is a national pastime, judging other people's parenting-- I just want to say I totally felt that way until I heard Elias, just like she says. And hearing Elias made me realize, oh, right. She actually is in a really tough situation, where she has these two kids, and they both have really strong feelings about this. And she doesn't want to crush either one of them. Anyway, listen. Here's Rachel with Elias.
好吧，在我继续之前，我想说，如果你听到这些并对这些父母感到评判——我知道你肯定会，因为评判别人的育儿方式是全民爱好——我只想说，在听到埃利亚斯说话之前，我也完全有这种感觉，正如瑞秋所说。听到埃利亚斯的话让我意识到，噢，对了。她确实处在一个非常艰难的境地，她有两个孩子，他们对这件事都有非常强烈的感受。她不想伤害他们中的任何一个。总之，听着。这是瑞秋和埃利亚斯的谈话。
What made you decide to become a vegetarian? Do you remember?
是什么让你决定成为一名素食主义者？你还记得吗？
Yep. And so basically, I just always thought that how they got meat was finding dead animals, like on the side of the road or something. But then I figured out they're actually killing them, and I thought it wasn't that nice. So I stopped eating it.
记得。基本上，我一直以为肉是捡来的死动物，比如在路边什么的。但后来我发现他们实际上是在杀害它们，我觉得这不太好。所以我不再吃了。
What do you think about other people eating meat?
你对其他人吃肉有什么看法？
I really don't like it.
我真的很不喜欢。
And what do you say about what you want to do with your life? Like, what's your goal in life? One of your goals. I know you have lots of them.
关于你的人生，你想做什么？比如，你的人生目标是什么？你的目标之一。我知道你有很多目标。
To get everybody vegetarian.
让每个人都成为素食主义者。
And what do you feel about animals?
你对动物有什么感觉？
I feel like, well--
我觉得，嗯……
Do you like them?
你喜欢它们吗？
Yeah. I love animals. And I know that there are only like 1,000 giant pandas left in the world. And also 30 Amur leopards, so they're pretty endangered.
是的。我爱动物。我知道世界上只剩下大约1000只大熊猫了。还有30只阿穆尔豹，它们非常濒危。
What do you think about the way people treat animals in general?
你对人们普遍对待动物的方式有什么看法？
Well, most of them not very nice. Like, think about lambs. They get killed for nothing.
嗯，大多数人都不是很友善。比如，想想小羊。它们被杀害却毫无意义。
Every time you talk about that, you start to cry, huh?
每次你谈到这个，你就会开始哭，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Lambs in particular are hard for you, huh?
特别是小羊让你很难过，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Yeah.
是的。
The family did stop eating meat at home after Elias asked. Though Rachel says that they actually didn't eat much meat before that either. Maybe once a week, they'd have fish or turkey. And for now, she and her husband's strategy with their two boys is that they try to get them to talk to each other and see each other's point of view, crossing their fingers that in the long run that's going to be best for both of them.
在埃利亚斯提出要求后，家里确实停止了吃肉。尽管瑞秋说在那之前他们其实也不怎么吃肉。也许一周吃一次鱼或火鸡。目前，她和丈夫对待两个男孩的策略是，尽量让他们互相交谈，理解对方的观点，并祈祷从长远来看这对他们俩都是最好的。
In the short run, though, it is complicated. You know, for any parent, there are always the things that you let go in the short run because you cannot fight every fight. And for a while, Theo, the one who eats meat, was secretly going out and getting turkey sandwiches with his dad after soccer. They would even dance this little turkey dance when they did it.
不过在短期内，情况很复杂。你知道，对于任何家长来说，总有一些事情你会在短期内选择放手，因为你不可能打赢每一场仗。有一段时间，吃肉的西奥会瞒着哥哥，在踢完足球后和爸爸偷偷去吃火鸡三明治。他们甚至在吃的时候还会跳一段小小的火鸡舞。
Or here's Rachel with Theo, the meat eater, on a Thursday. Fridays, the boys' school serves pizza, and you can get plain or pepperoni. And of course, Elias does not like it if Theo eats the pepperoni.
或者这是瑞秋和肉食者西奥在周四的谈话。周五，男孩们的学校会供应披萨，可以选择纯芝士或意大利辣味肠。当然，如果西奥吃辣味肠，埃利亚斯会很不高兴。
What do you think's going to happen tomorrow about the pepperoni pizza?
你觉得明天关于意大利辣味肠披萨会发生什么？
Well, since we don't have lunch at the same time, he will ask me, and then I'll just lie to say, I got peanut butter and jelly or any other snacks.
嗯，因为我们吃午餐的时间不一样，他会问我，然后我会撒谎说，我吃了花生酱果酱三明治或其他零食。
OK. Think it's going to work?
好的。你觉得这能行吗？
I don't know. It will be a hard choice to do peanut butter and jelly or cheese.
我不知道。选花生酱果酱还是芝士会是一个艰难的选择。
Mm-hmm. But what are you really going to do?
嗯。但你实际上打算怎么做？
Pepperoni.
吃辣味肠。
Hmm.
嗯。
So is it OK for your five-year-old to tell you they're going to deal with the situation just by lying to their siblings?
那么，让五岁的孩子通过对兄弟撒谎来处理这种局面是可以接受的吗？
[SIGH] Well, I will say that we have come some way since that was taped, and we don't lie about it anymore. And that was sort of, I think, an interim fix.
[叹气] 我想说，自从那段录音后我们已经有所进步，我们不再为此撒谎了。我认为那只是一种暂时的权宜之计。
What made him stop lying?
是什么让他不再撒谎了？
I think probably the more we are talking about it, the more I realized it didn't feel great. And so I was sort of being more open with Elias and saying, you have to realize that this is the reality of who Theo is and who he has the right to be. And Theo has his own choices, and he has the right to those choices, even though for you this doesn't make any sense right now.
我想可能是我们谈论得越多，我就越意识到那种感觉并不好。所以我开始对埃利亚斯更加坦诚，告诉他，你必须意识到这就是西奥的现实，他有权成为他自己。西奥有他自己的选择，他有权做出这些选择，尽管这对你来说现在根本讲不通。
One of the things you recorded was a conversation where you're talking to him about whether Theo has the right to do this.
你录下的谈话中，有一段是你跟他讨论西奥是否有权这样做。
Can you tell me a little bit about what happens with you and Theo, like when he wants to eat meat and you don't want him to and the pepperoni whole thing that happens every Friday?
你能告诉我一些关于你和西奥之间发生的事情吗？比如当他想吃肉而你不想让他吃，以及每周五发生的那些关于辣味肠的事情？
I normally kick him in the butt and yell at him a lot.
我通常会踢他的屁股，然后冲他大喊大叫。
Literally you kick him in the butt?
你是真的踢他的屁股？
Yeah.
是的。
Hmm. Do you think  that makes him want to eat meat less?
嗯。你觉得那样做会让他减少吃肉的欲望吗？
No.
不会。
Or do you think maybe the opposite?
或者你觉得会不会适得其反？
Opposite, probably.
大概是适得其反。
Hmm. And what do you think about when we talk about that you can't control other people and what they eat?
嗯。那么当我们谈到你无法控制别人吃什么时，你是怎么想的？
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
That it's not your job to tell other people what to do about what they get to eat, right? We've talked about that.
就是告诉别人该吃什么不是你的工作，对吧？我们谈过这个。
Right.
对。
Do you think it's true that you don't have a right to tell other people what to do?
你认为你没有权利告诉别人该怎么做，这是真的吗？
Yeah, I guess.
是的，我想是吧。
You guess. But it's hard?
你只是“想是吧”。但这很难接受，对吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I feel like when he says that, he's not totally sure he believes it yet.
我觉得当他说出这句话时，他自己还没完全相信。
I know. [LAUGHS] I agree.
我知道。[笑] 我同意。
You can hear in his voice, like, I know that this is the right thing to say--
你可以从他的语气中听出来，他仿佛在说：“我知道这是应该说的正确话——”
Exactly.
正是如此。
--but this can't be the truth, can it?
“——但这不可能是事实，对吧？”
Exactly. (SIGHING) Yeah.
没错。（叹气）是啊。
OK, an important fact-- Theo is not being crushed by Elias' demands. If anything, between the two of them, Theo is the dominant brother in most situations. He's outgoing, he's funny, he's a big personality in whatever room he walks into, and he gets his way with Elias all the time. Like, for instance, when the family took this day trip to visit Rachel's mom and coincidentally it happened to be the day of a herring run, which comes once a year. And so they stopped at this herring ladder, whatever that is.
好的，一个重要的事实——西奥并没有被埃利亚斯的要求压垮。如果非要说的话，在他们两人之间，西奥在大多数情况下是占主导地位的那个。他外向、有趣，无论走进哪个房间都是个个性鲜明的人物，而且他总是能按自己的方式行事。例如，当家里去拜访瑞秋的母亲时，巧合的是那天正好是鲱鱼洄游日，一年只有一次。所以他们停在那个鲱鱼梯旁，不管那是什么。
We are cheering for the herring, and they're doing their final leap into the water to go back to their spawning grounds. And we finally leave, we go back to my mother's house, and Theo runs to the refrigerator, opens the door, pulls out the jar of herring, goes, mmm, I can't wait to eat that herring.
我们正在为鲱鱼加油，它们正做着最后的跳跃，游回产卵地。我们最终离开，回到我母亲家，西奥跑向冰箱，打开门，拿出一罐鲱鱼，说，嗯，我等不及要吃那些鲱鱼了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And it was just like, wow. And of course, there then became Elias pleading and crying and hoping and hoping that Theo wasn't going to eat those herring, that we just saw all of his cousins.
当时的感觉就是，哇。当然，随之而来的是埃利亚斯的恳求、哭泣，他希望西奥不要吃那些鲱鱼，因为我们刚刚才看过它们。
Did he eat the herring?
他吃了吗？
Oh yes. So he ate the herring out on the porch. Elias, I think, cried in the living room.
哦，吃了。他在走廊上吃了那些鲱鱼。我觉得埃利亚斯在客厅里哭了。
Elias, however, is always coming up with new tactics. Like in the car recently, he made this proposal to Theo involving matchbox cars, and Rachel flipped on the recorder.
然而，埃利亚斯总是能想出新的策略。比如最近在车里，他向西奥提出了一个关于火柴盒小汽车的提议，瑞秋打开了录音机。
So tell me what you were just saying, that, Elias, you had a plan. What was the plan? You said, Theo, if you, what?
告诉我想你刚才说的话，埃利亚斯，你有一个计划。是什么计划？你说，西奥，如果你怎么怎么样？
Be a vegetarian for two weeks, I'll get you three new cars.
做两周的素食主义者，我就给你三辆新车。
Yay.
耶。
And what do you have to say?
那你怎么说？
Thank ooo.
谢谢你。
No, but does that seem like a fair deal? If you're a vegetarian for three weeks, you'd get three cars?
不，但这听起来是个公平的交易吗？如果你当三周素食主义者，你会得到三辆车？
Two.
两周。
Two weeks. Is it worth it to you?
两周。这对你来说值得吗？
Is that true, Momma? Will he really give me?
这是真的吗，妈妈？他真的会给我吗？
Yes.
是的。
This is not my negotiations.
这不是我的谈判。
Yes, I will. If you do it for three weeks, I'll give you eight.
是的，我会给。如果你坚持三周，我会给你八辆。
What will you give me if I do it one week?
如果我做一周，你会给我什么？
So this is where they are now. Rachel and her husband insert themselves in the middle of these negotiations, or they get dragged into the middle between the two boys. As parents, they have to ad hoc their way through each new thing the boys come up with on this. Like here with this matchbox deal, the boys could not agree on what is a critical part of any negotiation, of any contract, and that is the start date of the deal. Would their deal begin before or after Friday's pepperoni pizza day at school?
这就是他们现在的状态。瑞秋和丈夫插入到这些谈判的中间，或者他们被拖进两个男孩的争执中。作为父母，他们必须针对男孩们想出的每一件新事即兴应对。就像这次火柴盒小汽车的交易，男孩们无法就谈判中任何合同的关键部分达成一致，那就是交易的开始日期。他们的交易是在周五学校吃意大利辣味肠披萨之前还是之后开始？
I'm getting pepperoni.
我要吃辣味肠。
So you want it to start after F--
所以你想在周五之后开始——
I'm starting on Saturday.
我要从周六开始。
But being a vegetarian starts on Friday.
但素食主义应该从周五开始。
No!
不！
[LAUGHS] So--
[笑] 那么——
Fine. It starts on Saturday.
好吧。从周六开始。
All right, good. But can you guys shake on it? I think this is--
好的，很好。但你们能握手成交吗？我觉得这是——
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫]
--interesting.
——很有趣的。
Well, today on our program, people stuck in the middle. You know the saying "necessity is the mother of invention?" Being stuck in the middle of some situation is just like that because that is when ingenuity has to kick in. That is when you see people trying to MacGyver their way out, trying stuff that it is surprising to see anyone try.
今天我们的节目主题是“身陷困境的人”。你知道那句名言“需求是发明之母”吗？身陷困境就像那样，因为当人陷入困境时，创造力就必须迸发出来。那时你会看到人们试图发挥聪明才智去解决问题，尝试一些让人惊讶的方法。
We have three stories today of three radically different sorts of situations and their outcomes. From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们有三个关于三种完全不同处境及其结果的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Do You Hear What I Hear? So there's certain locations that we all find ourselves in sometimes where we're just supposed to sit and wait, stuck in the middle of not exactly nowhere, but nowhere interesting. I'm talking about the rows of chairs in airports that you sit in by the door for your flight, or doctor's office waiting rooms, and finally, the mundane spot that one man found himself in over and over. Sara Corbett has this story about her father-in-law.
第一幕：你听到了吗？我们有时会发现自己处于某些地方，只能坐在那里等待，困在不是什么偏僻地但也没什么意思的地方。我说的是机场登机口前排排的椅子，或者是医生的候诊室，最后，还有一个人反复发现自己所在的平凡之地。莎拉·科比特带来了关于她公公的故事。
I showed up for the first time at my father-in-law's house in 1992. He sat me down at the kitchen table, and we had a nice get-to-know-you sort of conversation. I was 24. Dick was about 60. And he pulled out a pen and took notes on what I was saying. At the time, I had no idea why he was doing this. But Dick is like this about everything that interests him.
1992年我第一次来到公公家。他让我坐在厨房桌前，我们进行了一次愉快的自我介绍式谈话。当时我24岁，迪克大约60岁。他拿出笔，把我说的内容记了下来。那时我不知道他为什么要这么做。但迪克对所有他感兴趣的事情都是这样。
He spent his entire career working for IBM, going back to the '50s and '60s, when working at IBM was like working at NASA. The kind of problems he worked on took weeks or months to solve, and he loved it. He's thorough, a process man. As Dick sees it, if something catches his attention, it's clearly worth gathering data on. And if it's worth gathering data on, it's worth getting to the bottom of, including, recently, a certain piece of music.
他整个职业生涯都在IBM工作，从50年代和60年代开始，那时在IBM工作就像在NASA工作一样。他解决的问题往往需要数周或数月，他乐在其中。他是一个做事彻底、讲究流程的人。在迪克看来，如果某件事引起了他的注意，那么收集相关数据就绝对值得。如果值得收集数据，那就值得深挖到底，包括最近的一段音乐。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
--ford Hospital.
——福特医院。
Hello. Could you do me a great favor? This is a very unusual call, but you know the music you have, the holding music? When you put me on hold, it plays it. Could you do that for me for a minute?
你好。能帮我一个大忙吗？这是一个非常不同寻常的请求，但你知道你们的保留音乐吗？当你把我挂在电话上时，它就会播放。能让我听一会儿吗？
OK.
好的。
I appreciate that very much.
非常感谢。
That's Dick. And for the last two years, he's been very, very interested in a piece of hold music.
那是迪克。过去两年里，他一直对一段保留音乐非常非常感兴趣。
The first time I heard it, when I was talking to Stamford Hospital, that's the call that started the whole thing. And I love the song. Just very unusual. It was bells and synthesizer, and I just-- clapping. It was an unusual piece. It's very hard to describe.
我第一次听到它是在和斯坦福医院通话时，那是开启这一切的电话。我爱上了这首歌。非常不同寻常。它是钟声和合成器的声音，我只是……鼓掌。那是一段不同寻常的音乐。很难描述。
He heard the hold music again when he called a medical billing center in Atlanta and again with his cardiologist. And he had a hernia, then a kidney stone. This one song, it turns out, is the hold music for Dick's entire health care network. He's 81, in great health, but 81 is 81, and he's the one who deals with all the appointments, the follow-ups, the billing, both for him and his wife, Marianne.
当他打电话给亚特兰大的医疗计费中心，以及再次联系他的心脏病医生时，他又听到了这段保留音乐。他患有疝气，后来是肾结石。结果证明，这同一首歌是迪克整个医疗保健网络的保留音乐。他81岁，身体状况良好，但81岁就是81岁，他是负责处理所有预约、后续跟进和账单的人，不仅是他自己的，还有他妻子玛丽安的。
So if I called any number of doctors in the area, I would hear that music. And every time I heard it, it would just again remind me of what in the devil is that tune.
所以如果我打给该地区的任何医生，我都会听到那段音乐。每次听到它，它都会再次提醒我，这到底是什么曲子。
He couldn't find the name of it. He couldn't find it, period, anywhere except on hold. And of course, he took notes on the phone calls where he was hearing it because Dick takes notes on every phone call. The song's not in the databases of music apps like Shazam and SoundHound, by the way, Dick tried it. To identify the song, he needed human help, and a surprising number of people in medical offices, strangers he met over the phone, were willing to take this on. These were exactly the kind of people Dick is always looking for when he's on a quest.
他找不到它的名字。他到处都找不到，除了在电话保留时。当然，他在通话时会记下笔记，因为迪克对每个电话都会做记录。顺便说一句，这首歌不在Shazam和SoundHound这类音乐应用数据库中，迪克试过了。要识别这首歌，他需要人类的帮助，而医疗机构里令人惊讶数量的人，那些他在电话里遇到的陌生人，都愿意尝试。这正是迪克在探索时一直在寻找的那类人。
The kind of person that would get into it.
那种会对此感兴趣的人。
A few people called their communications departments to see if they could turn anything up. No luck. A woman seven states away spent a whole weekend looking up songs online to try and find a match. Dead end.
几个人打电话给他们的通信部门看是否能找到线索。没有成功。一位远在七个州之外的女士花了一整个周末在网上搜索歌曲想找到匹配的曲子。死胡同。
But you know who was the least helpful? Dick's family. We did not get into it. Dick called us, his sons and daughters-in-law, and tried to hum the music over the phone. We blew it off. Dick described the hold song as haunting, but it was like a ghost none of us saw or even believed in, and he could tell.
但你知道谁最没用吗？迪克的家人。我们根本没兴趣。迪克打电话给我们，他的儿子和儿媳，试图在电话里哼唱那段音乐。我们敷衍了事。迪克形容那段保留音乐令人难以忘怀，但它就像一个我们谁也没见过甚至不相信存在的幽灵，他感觉得到。
I think when you get older, you get more of that in your life, where people are questioning whether you're really seeing it right or you remember it right or whatever. And that does get you to feel a little isolated, a little-- you know. Yes, you do. I did feel a little bit that way.
我想当你变老时，生活中这种情况会更多，人们会质疑你是否真的看对了，或者记忆是否准确。这确实让你感到有点孤立，有点……你知道的。是的，确实如此。我确实有那种感觉。
And like I can't go on keep asking people what's this music all about, and I can't describe it, and you sort of find that you better just let it go. And you don't want to, but it sort of fades after a while. Until you hear it again when you call another doctor's office, and then it's back.
我觉得我不能一直问别人这段音乐是什么，我无法描述它，你最好还是随它去吧。你不想这样，但它过了一段时间就会淡去。直到你打给另一家医生办公室时再次听到它，然后它又回来了。
So I'll put those in here.
所以我会把这些放在这里。
This is Dick going through some of the overstuffed cabinets at my house in Maine. He does this almost every time he comes to visit. He'll spend entire weekends in our basement sorting out the tools we rarely use, collapsing all the empty cardboard boxes that accumulate down there. He'll sift through old papers, double check our tax returns. He sees in my cabinets a bonanza of things that need sorting and labeling.
这是迪克在翻看我家位于缅因州的那些塞得满满的橱柜。他每次来做客几乎都会做这个。他会花整个周末在我们的地下室整理我们很少用的工具，把积压在那里的所有空纸箱拆平。他会翻看旧文件，复核我们的纳税申报单。他在我的橱柜里看到了需要整理和标记的宝藏。
I think I'll get a box for all your goodies like this, one of those cardboard boxes, before we throw them out. And I'll label it and put those together.
我想我会找个纸箱把这些好东西装起来，在扔掉之前。我会贴上标签，把它们放在一起。
This is the advantage of having a process man in the family. Dick stays with your problem until it's been solved, the cabinets or whatever. A couple of years ago, my husband and I were about to buy a new house when Dick swooped in and spent three days doing a copious market analysis, which made it clear that we were about to make a bad investment. He doesn't let himself off the hook for anything, big or small, because things don't let him off the hook.
这就是家里有个“流程控”的好处。迪克会守着你的问题直到它被解决，不管是橱柜还是其他什么。几年前，我和丈夫正要买一栋新房，迪克突然插手，花了三天时间做了详尽的市场分析，清楚地表明我们正要进行一项糟糕的投资。他不会让自己对任何事情敷衍了事，无论大小，因为事情也不会放过他。
Yeah, he's not fooling around.
是的，他不是在瞎折腾。
This is his wife, Marianne.
这是他的妻子玛丽安。
With life or feelings or getting things right or doing it complete, there is nothing in his life that is inconsequential. Everything matters.
对于生活、情感，或者是把事情做对、做完整，他生命中没有任何事情是无关紧要的。一切都很重要。
Can you think of anything that you've done that you did sloppily or hastily?
你能想到任何你做得草率或匆忙的事情吗？
Not really.
没有。
Nothing? [LAUGHS]
一件都没有？[笑]
I don't think so. It would be just not in my vocabulary to do something and say, OK, that's good enough. Let's go. And yet I don't say that's right. I really don't say that's right. And a lot of times I think that it's wrong, and I should be on to something else.
我想没有。做完一件事然后说“好吧，这就够好了，走吧”，这在我的词汇里是不存在的。然而我也不说“那是对的”。我真的不说那是对的。很多时候我认为那是错的，我应该去做别的事情。
I can hear the music in my head now. [HUMMING]
我现在脑海里能听到那段音乐了。[哼唱]
This woman, Denise Carter Stanley, was Dick's jackpot. She's the registrar at the medical imaging center where he went one day to get a CAT scan.
这位女士，丹妮丝·卡特·斯坦利，是迪克的大奖。她是迪克有一天去做CAT扫描的医学影像中心的登记员。
Great gal. She was a single mom, and she had been going to school at night, and we talked about a lot of things. And she was the kind of person that would get into it.
很棒的姑娘。她是一位单身母亲，晚上还要去上学，我们谈了很多事情。她就是那种会钻研进去的人。
Denise is on hold a lot inside the larger hospital network. She says she's been hearing the hold music every day for what she estimates is about an hour and a half a day for the last seven years. She likes the music. The first time Dick walked into her office, there was Denise playing the hold music, his hold music, on speakerphone at her desk.
丹妮丝在大型医院网络里经常被转接到保留状态。她说她过去七年里每天都能听到这段保留音乐，她估计每天大约要听一个半小时。她喜欢这音乐。迪克第一次走进她办公室时，丹妮丝正用免提电话播放着那段保留音乐，也就是他的那段。
In seven years, have other people asked you about the hold music?
七年来，有其他人问过你关于这段保留音乐的事吗？
Actually, they have. They have. But I just never got into it with them the way that he and I did. They were just like casually, yeah, that hold music, do you know who it's by? Like, no. But when he came in, it was really different. It was like he was really interested and really wanted to know.
事实上，他们问过。他们问过。但我从来没像和他那样深入探讨过。他们只是随口问问，“嘿，那段保留音乐，你知道是谁写的吗？”之类的。但我不知道。但当他进来时，真的很不一样。就像他真的感兴趣，真的想知道。
She called the IT department at her hospital. They thought she was crazy. She made more calls.
她给医院的IT部门打了电话。他们觉得她疯了。她又打了更多电话。
Let me see if I even still have all my information.
让我看看我是否还保留着所有信息。
Are you like Dick that you keep notes on all this stuff?
你像迪克一样，把所有这些东西都记下来了吗？
Yeah, I do. [LAUGHS] Because sometimes you just get fixated on something, and you just have to know. And you can't rest until you know.
是的，我记了。[笑] 因为有时你就是会专注于某件事，你必须得知道。在你弄明白之前你无法休息。
So you're a persistent person.
所以你是一个执着的人。
Yes, very.
是的，非常执着。
When you recognize somebody else who's persistent, do you have a special bond with them?
当你认出另一个同样执着的人时，你会和他们有特殊的纽带吗？
Yes. Because I know then they get me. I get them, and they get me.
是的。因为我知道他们懂我。我懂他们，他们也懂我。
So is that how you feel about Dick, that he--
所以这就是你对迪克的感觉，他——
Yes.
是的。
He's one of your tribe?
他是你的同类？
Yes.
是的。
Denise, digging around, finally turned up the key fact. The music came from Cisco, the company that provides the hospital's phone system. Cisco's the number one supplier of corporate phones like this in the world. Dick went to his local library, and a woman there-- I want to say her name on the radio because she cracked the case. Her name is Abby Sesselberg. She went to YouTube and found an audio recording. It's called simply "One Hour of Cisco Call Manager Default Hold Music."
丹妮丝在四处打听后，终于找到了关键事实。这段音乐来自思科公司，即提供医院电话系统的公司。思科是全球此类企业电话的第一大供应商。迪克去了当地图书馆，一位女士——我想在广播里提一下她的名字，因为她破解了这个案子。她叫艾比·塞塞尔伯格。她去了YouTube，找到了一个音频录音。标题很简单：“一小时思科呼叫管理器默认保留音乐”。
Can we do it? I want to hear it.
我们要听听吗？我想听。
OK.
好的。
[MUSIC - "OPUS NO. 1" BY TIM CARLETON AND DARRICK DEEL]
[音乐 - 蒂姆·卡尔顿和达里克·迪尔创作的《Opus No. 1》]
There are hundreds of comments posted about this song, pages and pages. And sure, some people can't stand it, but most of the comments are like this-- "Best hold music ever made. I love this song." "So addictively pleasant. Please, put me back on hold so I can listen to it some more." "I work in a call center, and this music is the best to listen to after dealing with rude customers." "I thought I was the only person who loved this." "I've been looking for this song for almost three years." Dick read these comments with relief.
关于这首歌有数百条评论，足足好几页。当然，有些人忍受不了它，但大多数评论都是这样的——“史上最棒的保留音乐。我爱这首歌。”“太令人上瘾了。求求你，把我转回保留状态，让我再多听一会儿。”“我在呼叫中心工作，这段音乐是在应付粗鲁客户后最好的慰藉。”“我还以为只有我一个人喜欢这个。”“我找这首歌找了快三年了。”迪克如释重负地读着这些评论。
"I just can't seem to help myself. I have been calling and asking another department on campus to put me on hold." See? She's calling and asking people to put her on hold because I love that hold music. You see there are other crazies, huh?
“我就是控制不住自己。我一直在给校区的另一个部门打电话，要求他们把我设为保留状态。”看到了吧？她给别人打电话要求对方把她挂在电话上，因为我爱那段保留音乐。你看到还有其他的“疯子”了吧？
Well, I must say from being compulsive about it in the early times when I was trying to find them, saying, why are you so compulsive about this? You crazy? And then I started to read this, and I must say it did a lot for my mental health.
嗯，我必须说，在早期我试图找到它时，人们说“你为什么对这个这么强迫症？你疯了吗？”然后我开始读这些评论，我必须说，这对我的心理健康大有裨益。
Yeah, you're feeling better about yourself now?
是啊，你现在感觉好多了吧？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
You're not alone.
你并不孤单。
My mental condition, yeah.
我的精神状态，是的。
The librarian also helped Dick find a title for the song. It's called "Opus No. 1." And that's when I finally got into it. Dick, this is for you.
图书管理员也帮迪克找到了这首歌的名字。它叫《Opus No. 1》。就在那时，我终于参与进来了。迪克，这是给你的。
My name is Tim Carleton, and I am the composer of "Opus No. 1."
我的名字叫蒂姆·卡尔顿，我是《Opus No. 1》的作曲者。
You're hard to find, by the way.
顺便说一句，你很难找。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Do you know that about yourself?
你知道这一点吗？
Yeah, I don't really have much of a web presence.
是的，我其实在网络上没什么存在感。
Tim was 16 years old when he wrote "Opus No. 1." It was recorded in 1989 on a four track tape by one of his high school buddies, Darrick Deel. Tim was a Yanni-loving computer nerd, messing around with a drum machine and a synthesizer in his parents' garage in California. That five minutes of tape is now on 65 million Cisco phone sets worldwide as the default hold music. It's what everyone hears unless someone inside the system makes an effort to change it.
蒂姆写《Opus No. 1》时才16岁。它是在1989年由他的高中好友达里克·迪尔用四轨磁带录制的。蒂姆是一个喜欢Yanni的电脑极客，在加州父母的车库里摆弄着鼓机和合成器。那五分钟的磁带现在被用作全球6500万台思科电话机的默认保留音乐。除非系统内部有人努力去改变它，否则每个人听到的都是这个。
Tim was in his 20s when he got a call from Darrick about "Opus No. 1." Darrick had taken a job at Cisco designing phone systems.
蒂姆在20多岁时接到了达里克关于《Opus No. 1》的电话。达里克当时在思科公司从事电话系统设计工作。
And he's like, dude, if you send this over and give us permission to do this, we can make this the default. I think I can get this in. And it was like putting an Easter egg in a DVD or software. Just like a little hidden gem that, oh yeah, the next time you're on hold, it might be my music. I just thought it would be a cool piece of trivia.
他说，老兄，如果你把它发过来并授权给我们，我们可以把它设为默认音乐。我想我可以把它加进去。就像在DVD或软件里放一个复活节彩蛋。就是一个小小的隐藏宝藏，下一次你被转入保留状态时，听到的可能就是我的音乐。我只是觉得这会是一个很酷的轶事。
So and then technically, what happened? So they license the music from you? I mean, do they renew their license every few years? Like, are you making any money off of it?
那么技术上发生了什么？他们从你这里获得了音乐许可吗？我是说，他们每几年会续约吗？你从中赚到钱了吗？
Not a penny. So I think that's probably my most legit claim as a music artist. I didn't make any money from my music.
一分钱都没有。所以我认为这可能是我作为音乐艺术家最“合法”的声称。我从我的音乐里没赚到一分钱。
Tim's not a musician anymore. He's an IT guy now. He manages the server at a bank in California.
蒂姆现在不再是音乐人了。他现在是IT人员。他在加州的一家银行管理服务器。
What is it like to be put on hold and hear your own music?
被挂在电话上听到自己的音乐是什么感觉？
It's really embarrassing when you're not expecting to hear that and then, all of a sudden, you have that memory pop up. I just start blushing immediately. It's just a different time. It's not the same person I am today.
当你没预料到会听到它，突然间那个记忆冒出来时，真的很尴尬。我会立刻脸红。那已经是不同时期了。那不是今天的我。
So is it sort of like looking back at a picture of yourself from 1987 and saying, oh, why was I wearing that outfit?
所以这就像回顾1987年的自己，说“噢，我当时为什么要穿那套衣服”？
Oh, exactly. That's exactly it.
噢，完全正确。就是那样。
So has it ever yielded anything good for you? I mean, if it hasn't made you money, has anybody ever bought you a drink in a bar, have you picked up women with it, or is there any--
那么它为你带来过什么好处吗？我是说，如果它没让你赚钱，有没有人在酒吧请你喝过酒，你有没有靠它搭讪过女性，或者有没有什么摇滚明星的应用场景？
No.
没有。
--rock star application here?
——摇滚明星的应用场景？
No, I don't think I've ever actually tried to use the, you know, I wrote the default hold music for a lot of companies.
没有，我觉得我从来没尝试过用“你知道吗，我为很多公司写了默认保留音乐”这句话来搭讪。
[MUSIC - "OPUS NO. 1" BY TIM CARLETON AND DARRICK DEEL]
[音乐 - 蒂姆·卡尔顿和达里克·迪尔创作的《Opus No. 1》]
Tim and Darrick are still friends, and Darrick's the only one after all these years making any sort of music. He creates new ring tones for phones, which Tim admits he's a little jealous of.
蒂姆和达里克仍然是朋友，达里克是多年后唯一还在做音乐的人。他为手机创作新的铃声，蒂姆承认自己有点嫉妒他。
It's something that people are choosing to put on their phone, as opposed to this music being forced on them. I think that would have been more entertaining to me.
这是人们选择放入手机的东西，而不是像这段音乐一样被迫接受。我觉得那对我来说会更有趣。
I see. So yeah, so you feel like your music has been forced on millions of people.
我明白了。所以你觉得你的音乐被强加给了数百万人。
[LAUGHS] Yes.
[笑] 是的。
So it's not exactly something to brag about.
所以这并不是什么值得吹嘘的事。
That's, I think, the source of my embarrassment, yeah.
我想这就是我尴尬的源头，是的。
I told Tim my father-in-law wanted a copy of the song to put on his iPod because he wants to play it around the house as he does chores and pays bills. In the comments on YouTube, lots of people said they wanted a copy. Tim found this almost impossible to fathom. But he and Darrick sent it anyway, full fidelity, in stereo.
我告诉蒂姆我公公想要一份这首歌拷贝放在他的iPod里，因为他想在家做家务和付账单时播放它。在YouTube的评论里，很多人都说他们想要一份。蒂姆觉得这简直不可思议。但他和达里克还是发了，高保真立体声版本。
[MUSIC - "OPUS NO. 1" BY TIM CARLETON AND DARRICK DEEL]
[音乐 - 蒂姆·卡尔顿和达里克·迪尔创作的《Opus No. 1》]
Sara Corbett is the co-author most recently of A House in the Sky . If you have not had enough of this song, "Opus 1" is available at better hospital phone systems and for a limited time at our website, thisamericanlife.org, in full fidelity stereo for your downloading needs.
莎拉·科比特是《天空中的房子》一书的合著者。如果你还没听够这首歌，《Opus 1》可以在较好的医院电话系统上听到，在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上也可以限时下载高保真立体声版本。
[MUSIC - "NOWHERE TO GO" BY THE FOUR FRESHMAN]
[音乐 - The Four Freshman创作的《Nowhere to Go》]
Coming up, the karate yid. That's not anti-Semitic, right, to say "yid"? And if it is anti-Semitic, is it one of those anti-Semitic things that I'm allowed to say because I am a Jew? Is even asking that question anti-Semitic? Anyway, Orthodox Jews skilled in karate-- you'll see what I'm talking about in a minute-- from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，空手道犹太人。说“yid”（犹太人）这个词不反犹吧？如果是反犹的，这是不是那种因为我也是犹太人所以可以说的词？连问这个问题本身是不是都反犹？总之，精通空手道的东正教犹太人——一分钟后你们就知道我在说什么了——来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Stuck in the Middle." Stories of people who cannot get out of some situation, some limbo they are caught in, and so they use ingenuity and guile or, anyway, unconventional means to get themselves unstuck. We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Sunrise, Sun-Get.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“身陷困境”。故事讲述了那些无法从某种处境中解脱出来，陷入某种困境的人，于是他们使用聪明才智、狡黠，或者无论如何，非常规手段来摆脱困境。我们现在来到节目的第二幕。第二幕，日出，日落。
This past October, there was a kind of wacky news story that was news for a day or so in New York City. It was on the cover of the tabloids. It was on all the local news channels in the tri-state area. And at its heart were people stuck in a kind of limbo. Mark Oppenheimer has more.
去年十月，纽约发生了一件古怪的新闻，一度成为头条。它登上了小报封面，出现在三州地区的所有地方新闻频道上。其核心就是一群陷入某种困境的人。马克·奥本海默对此有更多报道。
The news was pretty startling. A group of men, including a Brooklyn rabbi named Mendel Epstein, had been arrested for conspiring to kidnap a husband and torture him until he gave his wife a get. The get is simply a piece of paper a husband hands his wife saying, essentially, it's over. We're divorced. Jews can get civil divorces like anyone else. But if you're an Orthodox Jew, strictly following Jewish law, the get is the only real way to end a marriage.
新闻相当令人震惊。包括布鲁克林拉比门德尔·爱泼斯坦在内的一群男子因密谋绑架一名丈夫并对其进行折磨，直到他给妻子“get”（离婚证书）而被捕。“get”只是一张丈夫递给妻子的纸，本质上说，一切都结束了。我们离婚了。犹太人像其他人一样可以获得世俗离婚。但如果你是东正教犹太人，严格遵循犹太法律，“get”是结束婚姻的唯一真正方式。
Usually this goes off without a hitch. But sometimes a woman wants to get divorced and the husband refuses to give a get. That's where Rabbi Epstein came in.
通常这进展得很顺利。但有时女性想要离婚而丈夫拒绝提供“get”。这就是拉比爱泼斯坦介入的地方。
According to the complaint, Epstein talked about forcing compliance through the use of tough guys who utilize electric cattle prods, karate, handcuffs, and place plastic bags over the heads of the husbands.
根据起诉书，爱泼斯坦谈到通过使用电击棒、空手道、手铐的强硬分子，以及将塑料袋套在丈夫头上来强迫配合。
The criminal complaint against Epstein and a fellow rabbi named Martin Wolmark alleged that the rabbis agreed to arrange a beat down of a reluctant husband, and they were asking for more than $50,000 to do it. Here's the US attorney for New Jersey, Paul Fishman, laying this all out to the press.
针对爱泼斯坦和另一位名叫马丁·沃尔马克拉比的刑事起诉书称，拉比们同意安排对不情愿的丈夫进行殴打，并为此索要超过5万美元。这是美国新泽西州检察官保罗·费什曼向媒体披露的所有情况。
The charges are kidnapping and extortion, violent crime, to get Jewish men to give divorces that they wouldn't otherwise give. And it's not really an exercise of religion, it's really about money and violent crime.
指控是绑架和勒索、暴力犯罪，强迫犹太男子提供他们本不会提供的离婚。这并不是宗教行为，实际上是关于金钱和暴力犯罪。
When the story first broke, what kind of got lost is that it's not just about cash, karate, and cattle prods, it's also about women who were stuck, essentially trapped in failed marriages. For the past couple years, as a religion reporter, I've been interviewing Jewish women in just this situation. And it can be pretty horrible. Some men refuse to give a get because they still love their wives and hope to reconcile. But others just want leverage so they can demand, for example, lots of money.
故事刚爆发时，似乎被忽视的一点是，这不仅仅关乎现金、空手道和电击棒，它还关乎那些陷入失败婚姻、被困住的女性。在过去几年里，作为宗教记者，我一直在采访正处于这种境地的犹太女性。这可以是非常可怕的。有些男人拒绝提供“get”是因为他们仍然爱着妻子并希望复合。但另一些人只是想要筹码，以便他们可以要求，例如，一大笔钱。
Anywhere between half a million and $2 million, depending on the day and, I guess, the position of the sun in the sky.
取决于日子，还有我想是太阳在天空中的位置，金额在50万到200万美元之间。
This is Gital Dodelson. She's an Orthodox Jewish woman, and she's what's known as an agunah. That's the word in Hebrew for a woman whose husband refuses to give her a divorce. Literally it means a chained wife. Besides money, lots of money, Gital says her husband has a long list of demands for her to meet if she wants her get.
这是吉塔尔·多德尔森。她是东正教犹太女性，也就是所谓的“Agunah”。这是希伯来语中指丈夫拒绝给离婚证书的女性的词。字面意思是“被锁住的妻子”。除了金钱，一大笔钱，吉塔尔说如果她想要“get”，她的丈夫还有一长串要求她满足。
I have a four-year-old son. He wants 50-50 custody, where my son would be a week with me and a week with him.
我有一个四岁的儿子。他要求共同监护权，我儿子轮流和我住一周，和他住一周。
But Gital lives in New Jersey. Her husband's on Staten Island. The boy would have to enroll in two schools and alternate weeks. Keep in mind, Gital already has a civil divorce, and the custody and financial arrangements have been settled by a judge.
但吉塔尔住在新泽西。她丈夫在斯塔滕岛。孩子得入读两所学校并每周轮换。请记住，吉塔尔已经有了世俗离婚，监护权和财务安排已由法官定夺。
Gital says that her husband, who, by the way, didn't return my calls, is always changing what he's asking for. At one point, she says, he demanded they get rid of the coordinator who's overseeing the custody of their son. Another time, he insisted that she promise to tell the boy someday that the divorce was all his mother's fault. Gital says she should have seen it coming.
吉塔尔说她的丈夫——顺便说一句，他没有回我的电话——一直在改变他的要求。她说，有一次他要求他们解雇监督儿子监护权的协调员。另一次，他坚持让她承诺有一天告诉孩子离婚完全是他妈妈的错。吉塔尔说她早该料到的。
I was young and dumb. And there were a lot of things that maybe should have been red flags that I wasn't paying attention to. While we were dating, he told me once that he's always right. Now, I laughed because I don't know who says that when-- no one says that seriously, so I assumed he was joking. And he wasn't joking.
我当时年轻又愚蠢。有很多事情可能本该是危险信号，但我没有注意。我们在约会时，他有一次告诉我他总是对的。我笑了，因为我不知道谁会说那种话——没人会认真说那个，所以我以为他在开玩笑。但他没开玩笑。
A week into my marriage, I was looking back and kicking myself because, I mean, I should have stopped dating him right there. But I didn't realize. And by the time I realized, it was too late.
婚后一周，我回想起来懊悔不已，因为我本该在那时就停止跟他约会。但我没意识到。等我意识到时，已经太晚了。
I actually find it easier to explain now that he hasn't given a get for four years because the way he's trying to control me now through the get, that's what he tried to do throughout the whole marriage. Everything was subject to his control and subject to his demands. He had to have a final say in everything, even in what we were having for supper, or the brand of laundry detergent that I used, or anything. And nothing was too small for him to care about.
我现在解释他四年没给“get”的原因其实更容易了，因为他现在试图通过“get”来控制我的方式，正是他在整段婚姻中试图做的事情。一切都必须服从他的控制和要求。即使是晚饭吃什么，或者我用的洗衣粉品牌，任何事情他都必须拥有最终决定权。对他来说，没有任何事情是太小的。
Of course, there are always two sides to every divorce, and I tried to get her husband's side. When he didn't call back, I tried his parents, his uncle, even his grandmother-- his bubbe-- and none of them would talk to me. I finally spoke with her husband's lawyer, who disputed nearly every one of Gital's assertions. He said the sticking points for his client are tiny, reasonable things like what hour on Friday he can pick up his son so he doesn't have to drive after Sabbath begins at sundown.
当然，每场离婚都有两个方面，我试图了解她丈夫的立场。当他没回电话时，我尝试联系了他的父母、叔叔，甚至他的祖母——他的奶奶——他们都不愿意跟我说话。我最终和她丈夫的律师谈了，他反驳了吉塔尔几乎所有的断言。他说他委托人的症结是一些琐碎的、合理的事情，比如周五他可以在几点接儿子，这样他就不必在安息日日落后开车了。
But Gital's side of the story has been backed up by a rabbinic court called a beis din. A beis din is a group of three rabbis Orthodox Jews sometimes turn to to settle disputes outside the civil courts. When her husband wouldn't give a get, Gital tried to bring him before the beis din. But he refused to show up.
但吉塔尔的故事得到了一个名为“beis din”的拉比法庭的支持。“beis din”是三个拉比组成的小组，东正教犹太人有时会求助于他们以在世俗法庭之外解决纠纷。当她丈夫不给“get”时，吉塔尔试图把他带到“beis din”。但他拒绝出席。
So the rabbis issued something called a seruv. It's basically a contempt of court. It's supposed to ostracize him in the community. Gital's brother Aryeh is a full time scholar of Jewish law, and he says the seruv is usually an effective tool.
所以拉比们发出了所谓的“seruv”。这基本上是藐视法庭。它本应将他在社区中排斥。吉塔尔的兄弟阿里耶是一名全职犹太法律学者，他说“seruv”通常是一种有效的工具。
A seruv is, if followed properly by the community, an incredibly powerful thing. It sort of cuts them off from every aspect of Jewish life. I mean, you can't stand within 6 feet of him, 6 square feet, 8 square feet, whatever it is of him. You can't count him for a minyan.
“seruv”如果被社区正确遵循，是一件极其强大的事情。它基本上切断了他们与犹太生活各个方面的联系。我的意思是，你不能站在他6英尺、6平方英尺、8平方英尺之类的范围内。你不能把他算进“minyan”里。
The minyan is the quorum of 10 men needed for an Orthodox prayer service. It's sort of like telling a devout Catholic that he can't receive communion.
“minyan”是东正教祷告仪式所需的10名男子的法定人数。这有点像告诉一个虔诚的天主教徒他不能领圣餐。
You can't give him an aliyah. He can't be called up to the Torah in shul, which is a big honor, and he doesn't get that anymore. He can't serve as a hazzan there in the shul.
你不能给他“aliyah”。他不能在会堂里被叫上托拉，那是一个巨大的荣誉，他再也得不到了。他不能在会堂里担任领唱。
Chanting prayer. He can't do that. You're supposed to boycott his business, I think. Well, you can't be near him, right?
诵经祷告。他做不到。我想你被要求抵制他的生意。嗯，你不能靠近他，对吧？
You can't be near him. And so theoretically, if followed properly, it should be enough to both shame them as well as, on a practical level, they're losing all their contacts. You're not supposed to talk to him. You can't give him a ride, can't do him a favor.
你不能靠近他。因此理论上，如果正确执行，它应该足以羞辱他们，而且在实际层面上，他们失去了所有的联系。你不应该跟他说话。你不能让他搭车，不能帮他忙。
This sort of ostracism would have worked back in the old country, where you spent your whole life around the same couple thousand people. If you were the village cobbler and all of a sudden you had no customers, you probably figured that it made sense to give your wife a get. But in the modern world, a seruv doesn't always work so well. Aryeh believes that the Orthodox Jews on Staten Island, where his brother-in-law lives, are still treating him like one of their own. So the shaming and community pressure isn't working.
这种排斥在老家可能很有效，在那里你一生都围绕着同样的几千人打交道。如果你是村里的鞋匠，突然没有了客户，你可能会觉得给妻子“get”是有道理的。但在现代世界，“seruv”并不总是那么有效。阿里耶认为，他姐夫居住的斯塔滕岛的东正教犹太人仍然像对待自己人一样对待他。所以羞辱和社区压力并不起作用。
Gital, of course, could just walk away. She's already got her civil divorce. The finances are all settled, so is the child custody, but she can't get remarried. She's a 25-year-old woman. She'd like to have more kids.
吉塔尔当然可以一走了之。她已经有了世俗离婚。财务都解决了，孩子监护权也是，但她无法再婚。她是个25岁的女性。她想有更多的孩子。
And I should point out most Jews wouldn't care. Plenty of less religious Jews would be happy to marry Gital. But in the Orthodox world, where she was raised, where her whole family is, where she wants to stay, she can't make a new life for herself. Her ex-husband can cast about for a new wife and then give Gital a get if he finds somebody, but for Gital it's different.
我应该指出大多数犹太人不会在意。许多不太虔诚的犹太人会很乐意娶吉塔尔。但在东正教世界，她成长的地方，她整个家族所在地，她想要待的地方，她无法为自己开启新生活。她的前夫可以去寻找新妻子，如果他找到了人，就可以给吉塔尔“get”，但吉塔尔的情况不同。
What would it be like-- I mean, could you date?
那会是什么样子——我的意思是，你能约会吗？
Well, I mean, in my community, you don't date unless you're actively looking to get married. And since I'm already married, that would pose a little bit of a problem. I don't think I could find anyone who would be willing to date me under these circumstances where I say, hey, I'm looking to get married, but you might have to wait 2 or 3 or 4  or 10 or 20 years because there's this man who's refusing to give me the get.
嗯，我的意思是，在我的社区，除非你积极寻求结婚，否则你不约会。既然我已经结婚了，这会构成一点问题。我不认为我能找到愿意在这种情况下跟我约会的人，我会说：“嘿，我想结婚，但你可能得等2年、3年、4年、10年或20年，因为这个男人拒绝给我‘get’。”
And he doesn't feel any urgency because he can get out of it whenever he wants. He can give me a get and be done with the whole thing within a day as soon as he decides he wants to. So for him, it's just a waiting game where why not wait longer.
而且他没有任何紧迫感，因为他随时都可以摆脱它。只要他决定想要结束，他一天之内就可以给我“get”，把一切了结。所以对他来说，这只是等待游戏，为什么不等久一点呢。
If his demands were something that I could give, I would have given in a long time ago. Because this life is agony. I mean, to wait and wait and never know and to be tied together like this, I would give anything I could to be finished with it.
如果他的要求是我能给的，我早就让步了。因为这种生活简直是痛苦。我的意思是，这样无限期等待，永远不知道未来，被这样绑在一起，为了摆脱它，我愿意付出一切。
Almost anything. She wouldn't resort to violence or hire a rabbi like Mendel Epstein, the rabbi who was arrested in Brooklyn. Now, most of Epstein's work was above board. He'd advocate for women in rabbinic court, he'd serve as a go-between with the husband's family, that's how he made his living. But according to the FBI, Epstein took his work on behalf of women one step too far.
几乎一切。她不会诉诸暴力或雇用像布鲁克林被捕的拉比门德尔·爱泼斯坦那样的拉比。现在，爱泼斯坦的大部分工作都在法律允许范围内。他会在拉比法庭上为女性辩护，担任与丈夫家人的中间人，这就是他谋生的方式。但据FBI称，爱泼斯坦在女性委托人的工作上走得太远了。
Rabbi Epstein, I should mention, is currently out on bail. But neither he nor his lawyer responded to my request for an interview. However, about a year ago, before he was arrested, I actually met him, interviewed him at his dining room table. I recorded it on my phone. The interview started off pretty uneventful.
我应该提到，拉比爱泼斯坦目前被保释。但他和他的律师都没有回应我的采访请求。然而，大约一年前，在他被捕前，我实际上见过他，在他餐桌上采访了他。我用手机录了下来。采访开始时相当平淡。
So tell me what you do. Explain to me what you do.
那么告诉我你做什么。解释一下你做什么。
Well, on the simplest level, people come to ask if they should get divorced.
嗯，在最简单的层面上，人们来问他们是否应该离婚。
At some point, the interview kind of took a turn. Epstein told me about this case from 1992, when he got a call from a chained wife named Jennifer Klein. She had a civil divorce but no get, and now her ex-husband had kidnapped their young son and fled to Peru.
在某个时刻，采访发生了一次转折。爱泼斯坦告诉了我一个1992年的案件，当时他接到一位名叫詹妮弗·克莱恩的被锁住的妻子的电话。她有世俗离婚但没有“get”，现在她的前夫绑架了他们年幼的儿子并逃往秘鲁。
Epstein says he told her, call the FBI. She said she'd done that, but she'd also heard that Rabbi Epstein could do things that the FBI couldn't do. Epstein told me that the woman had already found a group of ex-CIA agents who were going to help find her husband and child.
爱泼斯坦说他告诉她：“打给FBI。”她说她已经那样做了，但她也听说拉比爱泼斯坦能做FBI做不到的事情。爱泼斯坦告诉我，那个女人已经找到了一群前CIA特工，他们会帮她找到丈夫和孩子。
How'd she find them?
她怎么找到他们的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You didn't find them.
不是你找到的。
She found them. Nothing to do with us. She found them.
她找到的。跟我们没关系。她找到的。
Epstein says she found them. Nothing to do with us. Epstein's daughter Batsheva, a lawyer, was sitting right next to him, so he was choosing his words carefully. But not super carefully.
爱泼斯坦说是她找到的。跟我们没关系。爱泼斯坦的女儿巴特谢娃是一位律师，她就坐在他旁边，所以他小心翼翼地选择措辞。但并没有非常小心。
As he continued with his story, he, the wife, the former secret agent man, and a Jewish scribe are all bound for Peru. They find the husband, break into the house. The kid's there. They save him. And then they head to the bathroom, where the hired muscle had found the husband.
随着故事继续，他、妻子、前秘密特工和一名犹太抄写员都前往秘鲁。他们找到了丈夫，闯入房子。孩子在那里。他们救了他。然后他们前往浴室，肌肉男在那里找到了丈夫。
The husband was already down on the floor, completely naked. Seems he was taking a shower with the Indian maid. We put him down.
丈夫已经躺在地板上，赤身裸体。看来他正在和印度女佣洗澡。我们把他制服了。
There were pictures of that.
有那张照片。
And then we had a conversation with him. He said the words he had to say, you please write-- he didn't say "please--" write and give a get to my wife. And I agreed to it and [INAUDIBLE] the messages. He did everything he had to do. So they also made--
然后我们和他谈了话。他说了他必须说的话，“请写——”他没说“请——”写并给我的妻子一个‘get’。我同意了，并[听不清]消息。他做了他必须做的一切。所以他们也做了——
So how did the CIA men convince him to give the get?
那么CIA的人是如何说服他给“get”的？
I don't know if we want to discuss that.
我不知道我们是否想讨论那个。
"I don't know if we want to want to discuss that," his daughter said.
“我不知道我们是否想讨论那个，”他的女儿说。
Let's just say it got a little physical.
只能说，这变得有点身体接触了。
[LAUGHS] Gotcha.
[笑] 懂了。
Now the CIA has this little pill.
现在CIA有这种小药丸。
Just to be clear, the guy was an ex-Delta Forces commando, not CIA, but whatever.
澄清一下，那个人是前三角洲部队突击队员，不是CIA，但无所谓。
The CIA has this little pill. They put it in his mouth. In a second, out cold. So the guy weighed about 200 pounds. We lifted the guy up, and we put him in the bathtub, locked the door.
CIA有这种小药丸。他们把它放进他嘴里。一秒钟，就昏倒了。那个人大约200磅。我们把他抬起来，放进浴缸，锁上门。
I asked the guy in the CIA, how long is he going to sleep. When will he wake up? So he said, Rabbi, we didn't do diagnostics here. You know, no one did a blood test like you do in the hospital. First of all, if he wakes up. I said what do you-- whoa! Now if it is, if he wakes up.
我问CIA的人他要睡多久。什么时候会醒？他说：“拉比，我们没在这里做诊断。你知道，没人像你在医院那样做验血。首先，如果他能醒来。”我说“你什么……哇！如果他能醒来。”
The Houston Chronicle reported on this story in 1992 and ran a photo of the woman and her son, reunited and posing with the hired gun from the Delta Forces. There are legends that this is exactly how these matters got settled back in the Eastern European villages. You hired a thug from the czar's army, he gave the husband a little talking to, and suddenly you had your get. Similar legends had floated around Epstein.
《休斯敦纪事报》1992年报道了这个故事，刊登了那位女士和儿子的照片，团聚并与来自三角洲部队的雇佣兵合影。有传说称这正是东欧乡村解决此类问题的方式。你雇佣一个沙皇军队的恶棍，他给丈夫一点“教训”，突然你就拿到了你的“get”。类似的传说在爱泼斯坦周围流传。
The violence that he's accused of doing now I would never have dreamed that that was what he engaged in.
他现在被指控犯下的暴力行为，我做梦也没想到他会参与其中。
This is Rivka Haut. 30 years ago, Rivka and a couple friends founded an organization to help free agunot. And back then, they worked with Mendel Epstein. She says, like everyone, she heard the rumors about some of his tactics. But she never imagined anything like what he's accused of now.
这是里夫卡·豪特。30年前，里夫卡和几个朋友创办了一个组织来帮助释放“agunot”。那时候，他们和门德尔·爱泼斯坦合作。她说，像每个人一样，她听说过关于他的一些手段的传闻。但她从未想象过像他现在被指控的那样的任何事情。
I was very saddened because I knew Mendel many years. And I still feel very sad about it. I figured the most he does is grab men and kind of threaten them. He's a big man. You've seen him-- you know that he's physically a big man. And I-- like a little fistfight or slapping around. That was my assumption.
我感到非常难过，因为我认识门德尔很多年。我现在仍然为此感到很难过。我以为他顶多就是抓住男人并威胁他们。他是个大块头。你见过他——你知道他身体上是个大块头。而我——就像那种小小的拳脚冲突或打耳光。那是我的假设。
Over the last few decades, as more Orthodox women decided it was OK to get divorced, Mendel Epstein got a reputation as the rabbi women could trust. He was willing to take the women's side. He even published a little handbook to guide women through the divorce process.
过去几十年里，随着越来越多的东正教女性决定离婚是可以接受的，门德尔·爱泼斯坦成了女性可以信任的拉比。他愿意站在女性一边。他甚至出版了一本小手册来指导女性度过离婚程序。
And Rivka says Epstein was her guy, too. She and her fellow activists were all Orthodox, but they were pretty modern. They had TVs in their houses, some of them wore pants, so they needed someone like Epstein to help them establish trust with the ultra-Orthodox women who needed their help.
里夫卡说爱泼斯坦也是她的人。她和她的活动同伴都是东正教徒，但她们相当现代。她们家里有电视，有些人穿裤子，所以她们需要像爱泼斯坦这样的人来帮助她们与需要帮助的极端正统派女性建立信任。
Mendel Epstein that I knew way back when was a mentor to us. He taught us a lot about agunot, and he was a great help to agunot. He tried to do the right thing. And he was out to get justice for women. And he did. He helped many, many women.
我当年认识的门德尔是我们的导师。他教了我们很多关于“agunot”的知识，他给“agunot”提供了巨大的帮助。他试图做正确的事。他一心为女性争取正义。他也确实做到了。他帮助了许多许多女性。
Then at some point, she can't remember if it was 10 years or 20 years ago, there was an incident, and her opinion of Epstein changed.
后来在某个时候，她记不清是10年前还是20年前了，发生了一起事件，她对爱泼斯坦的看法改变了。
The way it worked for me, we were working on a particular case. And he called me the night before, and he started saying very bad things about this woman, who was a wonderful woman, and I was shocked. And I said, what are you talking about? We're going out tomorrow. We're demonstrating on her behalf.
对我来说，事情是这样运作的，我们在处理一个特定的案件。前一天晚上他打电话给我，开始说这个女人的坏话，她是一个很棒的女人，我震惊了。我说，你在说什么？我们明天要出去。我们要为她示威。
He said, no, you're not, because you don't have a seruv. And I said, we have a seruv. I'm holding it in my hand. It's a rabbinic court document. He said, no, I got them to rescind it. I had them rescind it, and you can't go out. You don't have a seruv.
他说，不，你们不去，因为你们没有“seruv”。我说，我们有“seruv”。我正握在手里。这是一份拉比法庭文件。他说，不，我让他们撤销了。我让他们撤销了，你们不能去。你们没有“seruv”。
Why had he had it rescinded?
他为什么要撤销它？
Because he went to work for her husband.
因为他去给她的丈夫工作了。
Oh.
噢。
You know, if an attorney would do that, they'd get disbarred. But these rules don't apply, so he stopped working for her.
你知道，如果律师这样做，他们会被吊销执照。但这些规则不适用，所以他停止为她工作了。
So the husband made him a better offer.
所以丈夫给了他更好的待遇。
I guess. I guess. And that was a different face of him. And at that point, we had to tell women don't go. Don't ask him for help and don't go to him.
我想是的。我想是的。那是他的另一副面孔。从那时起，我们不得不告诉女性不要去。不要寻求他的帮助，不要去找他。
A colleague of Rivka's remembered this, too. Again, Epstein and his attorney declined to talk to me about any of this.
里夫卡的一位同事也记得这一点。同样，爱泼斯坦和他的律师拒绝就此与我交谈。
Right now, a lot of Orthodox Jews are pretty embarrassed by these husbands who won't free their wives. It's cruel, and they know it looks very bad to the outside world. A couple of solutions have been floated. One would be to grant women annulments, like in the Catholic Church. One well-known agunah in the Orthodox world, Tamar Epstein, recently announced that she considers herself free of her marriage, and everyone assumes it's because she found a rabbi to annul it.
现在，许多东正教犹太人对这些不愿解放妻子的丈夫感到非常尴尬。这很残忍，他们知道这对外部世界来说看起来很糟糕。已经提出了一些解决方案。一种是授予女性婚姻无效，就像在天主教会中一样。正统派世界中一位著名的“agunah”塔玛·爱泼斯坦最近宣布，她认为自己已经摆脱了婚姻，大家都认为是因为她找到了一个拉比宣布其无效。
But this idea is controversial. It hasn't caught on, not yet. So for now, if you're an agunah like Gital Dodelson, a desperate woman trapped in this limbo, paying some rabbi to intervene almost makes sense.
但这个想法是有争议的。它还没有流行起来，至少现在还没。所以现在，如果你是一个像吉塔尔·多德尔森那样的“agunah”，一个陷入这种困境的绝望女性，付钱给某个拉比进行干预几乎是有道理的。
You know what? The numbers that I've heard, my husband is demanding a lot more than that for the get. So you're telling me I'd pay a third party a small amount of money and he'll get rid of the problem for me instead of having to fight it out with my husband and give him much, much, much more? If you take out the fact that he's beating people up, that sounds like a pretty good deal.
你知道吗？我听到的数字，我丈夫要求的比这多得多。所以你的意思是我支付第三方一小笔钱，他就能帮我解决问题，而不是必须和我丈夫争斗并给他更多更多更多的钱？如果你把“打人”这个事实去掉，这听起来是一笔相当不错的交易。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Not that she'd ever hire someone to beat up her ex. She's not willing to go that far. But as it happens, there's an old Jewish teaching that recalcitrant husbands should be beaten, and it wasn't some schmuck from Brooklyn who said so. It was Maimonides, the 12th century Spanish rabbi considered the greatest Jewish sage of all time.
倒不是说她真的会雇人殴打她的前夫。她还没打算走那么远。但巧合的是，有一条古老的犹太教义称顽固的丈夫应该被殴打，而且说这话的不是来自布鲁克林的什么蠢货。那是迈蒙尼德，12世纪的西班牙拉比，被认为是历史上最伟大的犹太智者。
Maimonides wrote that a man could be beaten until he gave his wife a get. Here was his reasoning. "Deep down," he said, "all of us are torn between our good inclinations and our evil inclinations. And being beaten might be just what a man needs to drive out his evil side so that he can see the wisdom of releasing his wife." Maimonides doesn't say anything about karate chops and cattle prods, but the principle's the same.
迈蒙尼德写道，一个人可以被殴打直到他给妻子“get”。他的理由是：“在内心深处，”他说，“我们所有人都被撕裂在我们的善意倾向和邪恶倾向之间。而被殴打可能正是一个人为了驱逐他邪恶的一面所需要的，这样他才能看到释放妻子的智慧。”迈蒙尼德没说关于空手道劈砍和电击棒的事，但原则是一样的。
Mark Oppenheimer. He writes the Beliefs column for the New York Times , and he's working on a book about chained wives.
马克·奥本海默。他为《纽约时报》撰写“信仰”专栏，正在写一本关于被锁住妻子的书。
[MUSIC - "BLUE, PT. II" BY WAXAHATCHEE]
[音乐 - Waxahatchee创作的《Blue, Pt. II》]
Act Three, They Love a Man in a Uniform. So Egypt is an entire country that is technically now in the middle. They are in the transitional phase between what they were and whatever it is that they're about to become. Three years ago, during the Arab Spring revolutions, hundreds of thousands of Egyptians took to the streets to protest nearly 30 years of Hosni Mubarak's authoritarian rule. There were three weeks of this, then the Egyptian army ousted Mubarak.
第三幕：他们喜欢穿着制服的人。所以埃及是一个在技术上现在正处于中间的国家。他们处于从前身到即将成为的状态之间的过渡阶段。三年前，在阿拉伯之春革命期间，成千上万的埃及人走上街头抗议胡斯尼·穆巴拉克近30年的独裁统治。这持续了三周，然后埃及军队赶走了穆巴拉克。
Next came democratic elections. They elected the Muslim Brotherhood's candidate, Mohammed Morsi. Soon enough, you may remember, he tried to seize dictatorial powers for himself, passed something that said the judiciary could not question his decisions.
接下来是民主选举。他们选举了穆斯林兄弟会的候选人穆罕默德·穆尔西。很快，你们可能记得，他试图为自己攫取独裁权力，通过了一项法案，称司法机构不能质疑他的决定。
So then, this past July, another round of massive demonstrations. The military again intervened and threw out Morsi. Which means the army's in charge at the moment. Yes, there is an interim president, but he has as much presence and power as a polystyrene cup.
所以，去年七月，又进行了一轮大规模示威。军队再次干预并驱逐了穆尔西。这意味着目前由军队掌权。是的，有一位临时总统，但他拥有的存在感和权力就像一个聚苯乙烯杯。
It's the defense minister and head of the armed forces, General Abdel Fattah al-Sisi, who's generally regarded as running things for now, until a new constitution and a new round of elections. A referendum on an amended constitution was held this week. Official Egyptian news agencies say it passed with 95% voting yes.
是国防部长兼武装部队总司令阿卜杜勒-法塔赫·塞西将军，他目前普遍被视为负责管理事务的人，直到新宪法和新一轮选举。本周举行了关于修改宪法的公投。埃及官方新闻机构称，以95%的赞成票获得通过。
Sarah Carr is a reporter and a blogger living in Cairo. Her mother is Egyptian. Her dad is British. She grew up between Egypt and the UK, moved to Egypt to live over 10 years ago.
莎拉·卡尔是一位住在开罗的记者和博主。她的母亲是埃及人。她的父亲是英国人。她在埃及和英国之间长大，十多年前搬到埃及生活。
She reports for an English language independent news site in Egypt, and her blog, Inanities.org, is regularly cited as one of the best blogs and English language news sources coming out of the country. We asked her to write what it means to live in a country that is caught in the middle. Here she is.
她为埃及的一个英语独立新闻网站报道，她的博客Inanities.org经常被引用为该国最好的博客和英语新闻来源之一。我们请她写下生活在一个陷入中间的国家意味着什么。这就是她。
I've never in my life used as much caps locks as I did over the summer on Facebook as the country teeters on the political brink and Egyptians did battle in hysterical statuses and enraged comments. This battle reached its height after June 30, when Egyptians took to the streets, demanding the removal of President Mohammed Morsi. Later, after Morsi's removal, triumphant smoke-spewing army jets drew hearts in the sky. A friend remarked that the hearts resembled a pair of buttocks, which they did.
我这辈子从来没有像夏天在Facebook上那样频繁地使用大写锁定键，因为国家在政治边缘摇摆，埃及人在歇斯底里的状态和愤怒的评论中作战。这场战斗在6月30日之后达到了顶峰，当时埃及人走上街头，要求罢黜穆罕默德·穆尔西总统。后来，在穆尔西被罢黜后，凯旋喷烟的军机在天空中画了心形。一位朋友评论说，心形看起来像一对屁股，确实如此。
I spent much of the time after Morsi's removal on July 3 insisting that while I don't think that Morsi and his Muslim Brotherhood members should be hung, drawn, and quartered in public squares, that does not make me a spy, or a traitor, or a secret member of the group. This proved a controversial position as Egypt succumbed to the crude "it's us or them" logic beloved of general publics everywhere at times of great stress. One relative suggested that having grown up abroad, I could not possibly understand the complexities of the situation. Another sent me messages containing links to lunatic websites establishing incontrovertibly that Barack Obama is a secret member of the Muslim Brotherhood and that Morsi's tenure was a US-Zionist plot against Egypt.
穆尔西7月3日被罢黜后，我花了很多时间坚持认为，虽然我不认为穆尔西和他的穆斯林兄弟会成员应该在公共广场上被绞死、肢解，但这并不意味着我是一个间谍，或者叛徒，或者该组织的秘密成员。这被证明是一个有争议的立场，因为埃及屈服于处于巨大压力下的公众所钟爱的“我们或他们”的粗糙逻辑。一位亲戚暗示，由于在国外长大，我不可能理解情况的复杂性。另一位给我发来消息，链接到疯子网站，无可辩驳地确立了巴拉克·奥巴马是穆斯林兄弟会的秘密成员，穆尔西的任期是美犹针对埃及的阴谋。
An Egyptian Christian friend has it even worse and spends hours and days and months telling his Facebook friends that while he's not a member of the Muslim Brotherhood, he does not agree that Brotherhood members are animals. And yes, he does think that everyone, including them, deserves a fair trial.
一位埃及基督徒朋友情况更糟，花了数小时、数天、数月告诉他的Facebook朋友，虽然他不是穆斯林兄弟会成员，但他不同意兄弟会成员是动物。是的，他确实认为每个人，包括他们，都应该受到公正的审判。
Transitions are supposed to be about moving forwards, but Egypt's has been a manic loop de loop of hope and disillusionment, of beginnings that start with an ending, and never really moved beyond that point. We went from Hosni Mubarak's 30-year tenure to 17 long months of army rule. Then there was Morsi's brief one-year presidency, and now Egypt is back under military rule. The whole process is beginning again.
转型本应是关于前进的，但埃及的转型是一场希望与幻灭的疯狂循环，是一场以终结开始，却从未真正超越那一点的开始。我们从穆巴拉克的30年任期到了长达17个月的军队统治。然后是穆尔西短暂的一年总统任期，现在埃及又回到了军事统治之下。整个过程又开始了。
After Morsi was removed from office, the army and the media went on a campaign to convince Egyptians that we're facing a threat that could destroy the country. There were insurgents fighting in the Sinai, but that's been going on since 2011. There was an occasional bombing, and there were continuing clashes with Muslim Brotherhood supporters who refused to leave two massive sit-ins in Cairo.
穆尔西被罢免后，军队和媒体开展了一场运动，说服埃及人我们正面临可能摧毁国家的威胁。西奈半岛有叛乱分子在战斗，但这自2011年以来一直在进行。有偶尔的爆炸，还有与拒绝离开开罗两个大规模静坐抗议的穆斯林兄弟会支持者的持续冲突。
Television presenters soon conflated all these things. They stopped calling supporters of the Muslim Brotherhood disease-ridden lunatics and started calling them terrorists. The government blamed the Brotherhood for a bombing in the town of Mansoura that killed 16 people, then officially declared them a terrorist organization and promised jail sentences for all its members. This despite the fact that the Brotherhood publicly condemned the bombing.
电视主持人很快混淆了所有这些事情。他们不再称穆斯林兄弟会的支持者为“充满疾病的疯子”，而是开始称他们为“恐怖分子”。政府将曼苏拉镇造成16人死亡的爆炸案归咎于兄弟会，随后正式宣布他们为恐怖组织，并承诺对其所有成员处以监禁。尽管事实是兄弟会公开谴责了这次爆炸。
The war, if that's what it is, has finally caught up with the propaganda against it, and today you can't turn on the TV without seeing ladies in red, white, and black warbling declarations of undying love for the armed forces against a hodgepodge of library shots of military exercises and enormous rockets being launched in an unknown direction, possibly towards the Al Jazeera headquarters. Al Jazeera is viewed as a Brotherhood mouthpiece and is currently enemy number one in Egypt. In the most recent expression of this, four Al Jazeera English journalists were arrested at the end of December on charges of spreading lies harmful to state security and joining a terrorist organization. The journalists had been interviewing members of the Muslim Brotherhood in a swanky Cairo hotel.
战争，如果算的话，终于追上了针对它的宣传，今天你无法打开电视，而不看到身穿红、白、黑色的女士们对着武装部队表达永恒的爱，伴随着一堆关于军事演习和巨型火箭向未知方向发射的图书馆片段，可能是向半岛电视台总部。半岛电视台被视为兄弟会的喉舌，目前是埃及的头号敌人。在最近的表现中，四名半岛电视台英语记者在12月底被捕，罪名是散布损害国家安全的谎言并加入恐怖组织。这些记者在开罗一家豪华酒店采访了穆斯林兄弟会成员。
The police, once reviled as corrupt, vicious thugs, have made a dazzling comeback of the Robert Downey, Jr. variety, despite the fact that absolutely nothing has changed with an institution that is crawling with corruption and abuse. They're back to kidnapping activists for hours and dumping them in the desert, assaulting and torturing detainees, and essentially acting as a military regime's heavies. In August, their men killed hundreds of people during a dispersal of the Rabaa al-Adawiya Muslim Brotherhood protest. And a few weeks later, the authorities erected a statue in tribute to the police, the armed forces, and the people on the site of the deaths.
曾经被视为腐败、凶残暴徒的警察，以“小罗伯特·唐尼”的方式华丽回归，尽管一个充斥着腐败和虐待的机构绝对没有任何改变。他们又回到了绑架活动人士数小时并把他们扔在沙漠里，袭击和折磨被拘留者，本质上作为军事政权的打手。八月，他们的人在驱散拉比亚·阿达维亚穆斯林兄弟会抗议期间杀害了数百人。几周后，当局在死亡现场竖立了一座雕像，以纪念警察、武装部队和人民。
If there was any public protest it was inaudible, what with the din of the party poppers, and people cheering, and the sound of army tribute pop song "God Bless the Hands."
如果有任何公众抗议，那也是听不见的，因为到处都是礼花、人们的欢呼声，以及军队致敬流行歌曲《上帝保佑这些双手》的声音。
[MUSIC - "GOD BLESS THE HANDS"]
[音乐 - 《上帝保佑这些双手》]
That song is now a wedding party favorite.
那首歌现在是婚礼派对的最爱。
This cheerleading on of a massive crackdown demonstrates a real and genuine public appetite for authoritarian measures. And it's understandable to an extent. There is a general perception that under the Brotherhood, the country was about to sink into the abyss and that the army intervention dragged it back from the edge. A new process law now makes it illegal for 10 or more people to hold a demonstration without obtaining prior police permission. In effect, the crackdown is undoing the revolution. Many Egyptians are thrilled.
这种对大规模镇压的加油表明公众对威权措施有着真实且纯粹的渴求。在某种程度上是可以理解的。人们普遍认为，在兄弟会的领导下，国家即将沉入深渊，军队的干预将其从边缘拉了回来。一项新的程序法现在规定，10人或以上在未经预先获得警察许可的情况下举行示威即属非法。实际上，镇压正在抵消革命。许多埃及人为此感到兴奋。
But the media has played an instrumental part in whipping up the hysteria about the Brotherhood, stoking fear with endless unsubstantiated rumors about shady foreign elements seeking Egypt's destruction, of youth activists being American agents, and Brotherhood members taking orders from Qatar. This has got a bit out of hand. And 2014 began with the news that the public prosecutor is opening an investigation into whether a television advert for mobile phone giant Vodafone featuring a popular glove puppet carries secret coded Brotherhood messages.
但媒体在煽动关于兄弟会的歇斯底里方面发挥了工具性的作用，通过关于寻求埃及破坏的阴暗外国元素、青年活动人士是美国代理人、兄弟会成员接受卡塔尔命令的无尽毫无根据的谣言来煽动恐惧。这有点失控了。2014年以检察官开始调查移动电话巨头沃达丰的一则带有流行手套木偶的电视广告是否携带秘密编码的兄弟会信息的消息开始。
General Sisi, the head of the army, at the moment can do no wrong, and his relationship with Egyptians can only be described as a lovefest. A few days ago, he gave a tantalizing hint to his fans that he might consider running for president, saying, when Egyptians say something, we obey. And I will never turn my back on Egypt.
军队首脑塞西将军目前“不会出错”，他与埃及人的关系只能被描述为一场爱的盛宴。几天前，他给粉丝们留下了一个挑衅性的暗示，说他可能会考虑竞选总统，他说：“当埃及人说某件事时，我们服从。我永远不会背弃埃及。”
Last month, a voice recording, allegedly an interview with Sisi, was leaked. In it, Sisi was asked about whether he has presidential ambitions, and he responded by talking about dreams he has had involving Omega watches, and a sword with "there is no god but God" written on it, and assassinated president Anwar Sadat talking to him. It was all very weird and alarming but made no perceptible dent in his popularity.
上个月，一段语音录音被泄露，据称是塞西的采访。在录音中，当被问及是否有总统野心时，他通过谈论他做的梦来回应，梦涉及欧米茄手表，一把写着“万物非主，唯有安拉”的剑，以及被暗杀的总统安瓦尔·萨达特在和他说话。这一切都很奇怪且令人担忧，但在他的受欢迎程度上没有产生任何明显的削弱。
Meanwhile, the loop de loop loops again. Just this past week, Egyptians voted in a referendum on a constitution for the third time in three years. January 25, Tahrir Square, and the revolution and its possibilities are a distant memory now, locked up in prisons and lying flat and lifeless on downtown Cairo's walls in faded, dying graffiti. I remember on January 29, 2011, we wandered, stunned, through the streets of downtown Cairo amongst the still smoldering remains of police cars and young men writing graffiti declaring the end of Mubarak. For a very brief moment, the streets along the fiefdom of the Interior Ministry and its expansive network of police informants were ours.
与此同时，循环再次循环。就在过去一周，埃及人第三次在三年内就宪法进行公投。1月25日，解放广场，以及革命及其可能性现在已是遥远的记忆，被锁在监狱里，平躺在开罗市中心的墙上，在褪色、垂死的涂鸦中毫无生机。我记得2011年1月29日，我们惊呆了，在开罗市中心的街道上徘徊，在警察汽车和年轻男子写着宣布穆巴拉克结束的涂鸦的余烬中。有那么一瞬间，沿着内政部及其庞大的警察线人网络的地盘的街道是我们的。
Then this past November, I was at a demonstration that was broken up by the police. The police used a primitive sort of water cannon, a large hose, really, to douse protesters before going at them with truncheons. In less than 10 minutes, it was all over, and there was nothing left. And if it wasn't for the water on the ground, you would have never guessed anything had happened.
然后去年十一月，我在一场被警察驱散的示威中。警察使用了一种原始的喷水器，实际上是一根大软管，在用警棍攻击抗议者之前喷洒他们。不到10分钟，一切就结束了，什么都没剩下。如果不是地上的水，你永远不会猜到发生过任何事。
Sarah Carr in Cairo. She writes about Egypt on her blog, Inanities.org.
莎拉·卡尔在开罗。她在博客Inanities.org上撰写关于埃及的文章。
[MUSIC - "REPEAT" BY THE WIMPS]
[音乐 - The Wimps创作的《Repeat》]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Dana Chivvis and Allison Davis. Our story about Rachel and her vegetarian son was co-produced with Jyllian Gunther.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼希、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。达娜·奇维斯和艾莉森·戴维斯提供制作帮助。我们关于瑞秋和她素食儿子的故事是与吉莉安·冈瑟共同制作的。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。伊莉丝·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安·马修韦茨管理我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供音乐帮助。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. You know, I was just thinking about this the other day, how young he and I both were. We were so young when we made the deal to start the radio show, and we had that woman lawyer helping us, and we were both so strong-headed. I have a recording.
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。你知道，我前几天还在想这个，我们俩当时有多年轻。我们开始制作电台节目时是多么年轻，我们有那位女律师帮助我们，我们俩都那么固执。我有一个录音。
Fine. It starts on Saturday.
好的。从周六开始。
All right, good. But can you guys shake on it? I think this is--
好的，很好。但你们能握手成交吗？我觉得这是——
[SCREAMS]
[尖叫]
--interesting.
——很有趣的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "STUCK" BY MIDDLE CLASS FASHION]
[音乐 - Middle Class Fashion创作的《Stuck》]
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——公共广播国际。